what has this been like for you because
this has gone so it's gone everywhere
it's so viral the dance moves all of it
the movie hasn't even come out yet I
know I'm very excited uh it's what you
always hope for as a producer and uh you
know it's just a great it's great we I
never expected it and I'm thrilled that
it's happening people seem to really
like Megan and you've got this guy James
Wan next to you a lot of talk about you
guys teaming up taking over the horror
World anything you can tell us
um we're we're talking and talking and
hopefully soon we'll conclude an
agreement and work together and make
lots of uh great fun scary movies like
Megan
what's wrong with you don't worry Katie
I won't let anything harm you I have two
crossovers to ask you about one is that
there's a lot of talk that Megan could
team up with Annabelle and Chucky is
that something that you guys have talked
about we have been talking about it all
day actually what James's idea is to do
a uh a Justice League but the the Dolls
team up together to fight a third force
of evil so the adults don't fight each
other but instead they they use their
strength to fight someone else and they
cooperate which I which I think would be
great Justice League Avengers type thing
and then once again I am begging for my
Freaky Friday air buds are my freaky
happy death day crossover movie I know
me too I want it so badly I'm not sure
we're ever gonna see it but I but I
would love to see it too what do you
need me to do personally how do I make
this happen I just tweet tweet about it
tweet about it tweet at you every day
okay okay okay
and what a universal monster movie are
you talking I think you're doing uh what
you're the Wolfman with Ryan Gosling
he's so excited why was he the perfect
one for that
he is a great wolf man he he he actually
he was the one who approached us he came
he was the one who's been so passionate
to be the wolf band so it really came
from him and when that happens it's very
rare and it means the actor's gonna be
triply good in the park you're always so
fun to interview because I'm like which
of the 85 in production projects am I
going to ask Jason Blum about today
well we're working on I just talked to
David Gordon green who's busy on the set
of The Exorcist I talked to him about an
hour ago and uh and uh we have Megan
next year we have a few others and then
next next October we have The Exorcist
okay would you call Chris Landon after
this I always call Chris Landon I call
Chris Landon and beg him to work for us
every day lastly how long did this
Ensemble take to put it it took a while
we had a team of people that took a
while this is my Halloween outfit but I
had so much fun wearing it for a
Halloween party I beg to wear it again
for the premiere and luckily I was
allowed I feel like you're about to lip
sync for your life I may laughs
[Music]